belarus has agreed to hold talks with
the european union over the migration
crisis on its borders german chancellor
angela merkel spoke to alexander
lukashenko on the phone for a second
time on wednesday a move that's been met
with some criticism along the border
between belarus and eu member poland
there are signs of de-escalation after
clashes between polish police and
migrants people stranded on the
belarusian side started boarding buses
to take them away from the frontier
on the move again
migrants on the belarus side of the
border with poland are being brought to
an unknown location
that's according to polish authorities
for warsaw it doesn't signal an end to
the crisis
let me remind you that this isn't just
an attack on the polish belarusian
border it all started with the attack on
the lithuania belarus border that was
just the beginning then the belarus
latvia border was attacked so it's
simply an attack on the borders of the
european union
at the moment it's concentrated at the
part of the eu border that's under our
polish protection
for some migrants conditions have
improved while they wait and see if they
can get into the eu
they've been brought to a shelter like
this one in belarus far from where they
had hoped to be
for those wishing to get to germany
any hopes of berlin allowing them entry
have been dashed
i think the current developments that
we're seeing there clearly show once
again the road to belarus is a dead end
for most people who want to go to
germany there are no plans to start
approving them there
back in belarus some migrants fear what
lies ahead for them
belarusian side will not let us go here
because we are weapons of belarusian
government belarus
all immigrants here knows that belarus
uses
u.s immigrants just like of open
with a european country
as many migrants wait for a clear path
forward belarusian leader alexander
lukashenko has said he is willing to
hold talks with the eu on solving the
crisis but this has angered many
european leaders as they don't recognize
him as the legitimate leader of belarus
and dw's bomb revisal is in the polish
border region and joins us from there
barbara another freezing night there
yesterday belarus began bussing migrants
away from the border to emergency
shelters what have things been like
where you are today
i mean it's been relatively quiet on the
polish side but we saw that the polish
guard polish border guards put out a
notice saying that at another point not
far from where we're standing here 500
migrants tried to breach the border so
they tried in a really large group to
sort of push through
with the idea that you know the police
will catch some but maybe not all of
them so we don't know how many of them
made it through and that shows that this
is not totally over where the eyes of
and cameras of the media are on the
belarusian side we see the buses and we
see people having been brought to a
warehouse but out in the forests here
in this huge border region there are
still hundreds of migrants who are
trying to make their way into the eu
now you and your team went out last
night into that forest with some aid
workers and met a syrian migrant uh tell
us more about what happened
it was a really heart-rending experience
because we got a tip from local aid
workers that they somebody had called
for help from the forest and we went out
into the forest with them it took four
hours to find the man and he was a
syrian man from homs totally exhausted
he had fallen ill on the trail his group
left him behind but at least they sent a
location pin
to this aid group who then went to find
him they couldn't help him on his way he
was too ill he had to go to hospital and
the point now is that they're trying to
keep the polish
police from pushing him back across the
belarus border because that would be
something that this man certainly would
not survive
and germany's angela merkel has again
phoned belarusian leader alexander
lukashenko what's happening on the
diplomatic front
she has been incredibly busy she has
also been talking to the polish
government yesterday
in order to sort of calm their nerves
because they were complaining now
they're talking to lukashenko they're
not talking to us and we're sort of the
main players in this whole drama so she
also talked to them but she's also
contacted lukashenko again instead of
put her weight uh once once more maybe
one last time in one of these
international crisis
up against this this big problem and
said you you have to stop this we will
not be blackmailed in the way
that we will sort of give in to you we
will not lift the sanctions and no there
were more sanctions opposed on him
but you cannot do this it's a
humanitarian crisis and so he seems to
be changing his game and doesn't want to
be left as the bad guy causing more
people to die and wants to sort of show
yeah i'm reasonable i'm doing this just
in order to gain favor and to sort of
look better in the international eyes
barbara thank you dw's barbara weasel
speaking to us from poland
and i'm joined now by gerald canales
he's a former gov german government
migration adviser and co-founder of the
think tank the european stability
initiative mr canals welcome to dw
are eu pushbacks a violation of refugees
human rights
well some questions are very easy to
answer and this is one
yes
obviously
all you need to do is read the schengen
border codex the law
that regulates what is allowed at eu
borders all you need to do is read a
judgment by the highest european court
in luxembourg
from december 2020
on the hungarian asylum law which
practices and
legalizes pushbacks there and which
found that this was in violation of eu
law
and in fact the polish prime minister is
not even arguing that this is in line
with eu law he simply says
and explains that eu law
should be
irrelevant because poland is facing an
invasion and so
these basic principles these conventions
are suspended
legally it's clear
unfortunately politically it's also
clear that
there is now a consensus in the eu to
just uh
accept this violation
you said recently that we need humane
control what do you mean by that
well your main control would mean doing
what the laws and the conventions
on the rights of children refugee
convention human rights convention
judgments foresee
the point about basic human rights is
that they
matter in a time of crisis under
pressure and clearly
this is a deadly trap
that was sprung on the eu by lukashenko
and on these people they were lured into
belarus
they might not be refugees but for this
you need to have a status determination
but they are human beings with human
dignity and to push them back into the
forest into the hands of lukashenko's
security forces that is not your main
control your main control would be to
say
our laws are clear those who reach
poland uh have a right to apply for
asylum in poland uh or in the european
union
and if we want to stop people going to
belarus we need to think about other
ways to do that that is an effort
um
but it is worth it if you believe in
fundamental uh conventions and human
rights
there's been some criticism of angela
merkel's discussions with alexander
lukashenko in your opinion was it right
for merkel to speak directly to
lukashenko
well if you cannot think of any other
way
to um
deal with this massive humanitarian
crisis i mean we're talking about
thousands of people at risk of death and
we're talking about a dictator who's
been prepared to torture his own people
lukashenko
you are in a trap and
lukashenko is winning on this
he is being talked to he holds the fate
of these people in his hands and
if we do not want them to suffer
and since the european union couldn't
think of any other strategy it is now
appealing to him to help us and of
course this is going to have a price and
the price we see already in the belarus
media the official media where he
celebrates this as a victory he forced
the eu to talk to him
although nobody wanted to talk to him
after his human rights
violations and suppression of his own
population since
the last elections
all right gerald klaus gerald class
we'll have to leave it there former
migration advisor to the german
government thank you very much for your
time